500 looks great to me now this one here
let's just put in an intermediate step
it's 1/2 times the square root of 32 so
if I have that half hanging out front
there
what can I pull out of the square root
of 32 there'll be a nice quick way to
simplify this any takers I can take out
the square root of 60 and what H is 16
by the way I'm not saying 8x a big
number 16 yeah yes that's right not a
finger and no useful 16 is a square
number so apply pool there do you agree
squared of 16 of course is four and a
half times four is exactly what Daniel
and therefore do to my last one here to
finish off what we pulled out this time
yeah so this time we've got squared 4
squared 11 when you take the square root
of the form that's what makes it a 2 and
7 times 2 is 14
can you just point out I think this is
exactly how I would have said now but
just be watchful it's really easy while
you're sort of it autopilot or brushing
through a question to see that say I'll
play out a form
did you notice as I was talking about
these questions you're not pulling out
for you're pulling out the square root
of 4 which is 2 and that's why I
descends up 14 not 28 it's very easy to
sort it you click really have in your
mind hard pull out before it's not a
form so just be watchful what you're
doing Adrienne 11 books good job you've
already got this on your working so you
don't need to write it again but I've
rubbed it off so that's why I put it
back
you just did this question right square
root 20 to 75 we simplified it in this
exact way you guys know what the square
root of 25 is so once you evaluate that
up your answer of 5 root 11 this is with
concrete numbers okay one of the things
we like to do is mathematician to say
you know what this is always true no
matter what kind of combination of
numbers you've got so we would put this
together as a rule we've already written
this that if you've got a product of
true numbers I can split it apart into
its does anyone remember if you got a
product one of the two numbers that you
get out they called factors very good
you can split a product into its factors
you can split one square root into two
so in this case what I can say is it's
the square root of a time's the square
root of B so let me be a positive
numbers different weird things happen
when I am being negative but we're just
dealing with positive numbers the ones
we can measure but once they come out
things like Pythagoras is doing now what
I want you to notice is just like if you
for example take on the most famous
equation in form of history which is now
I know what the equals mc-squared
does anyone know what the C is in this
case C it is a particular constant the
particular constants the speed of light
which is really fast it's a really big
number what happens when you square a
big number
it gets even bigger okay so all this is
saying is if you've got a little tiny
bit of mass that's what the M is for
right you can convert that into a whole
lotta energy and that's all
so behind nuclear power nuclear weapons
and so on okay but every equation
because it's an equal sign right can
also be read in Reverse if I can say a
little bit of maths would give you a lot
of energy I can also say if you've got a
lot of energy you can convert that into
mass the same thing is happening here
right we're used to going in this
direction take one number split it into
its pieces factors right and you can get
two spirits out of one but you can just
as easily go in the opposite direction
write the same equation right there with
me if I had to separate square roots so
long as they're positive and if you
multiply them you couldn't go back where
you came from right writing an equation
this equals that is the same as that
equals this it's the same thing but it
means I can go in different directions
depending on what's convenient to me so
thank you okay so if I ask you to do
this okay
just following straight on the square
root of 7 times the square root of 5
they've been following this idea if I
wanted to combine these two into one
square root 1 7 times 5
now why is this useful to me I can think
of at least two reasons number one
sometimes it's more convenient to write
one number rather than two and you
remember before the reason we split this
apart is because this is useful do you
agree
your ever we simplify that so that was
good so sometimes pleading apply has a
purpose but do you see here you don't
get anything of an advantage when they
split apart you can't do anything with
this you can't do anything with that
do you like great no two squares just
hanging out you might as well rather
than write two numbers you might as well
write them as one is one other quick
advantage which is that um the square
root of seven they don't know this very
70s roughly like just how to get it's
between the squared 4 squared 9 spike
which is between 2 & 3 so like two and a
half something like that I don't
actually know same thing with this one
and I think it's about an event maybe to
22 or 2.1 thereabouts now I've got a
rough idea what each of these is I could
multiply them together we've landed off
idea but clearly it's much better to say
if I have to estimate one number
[Music]
that's better isn't it what's a square
number really close to this 36 is very
close so the square root of 36 is
exactly 6 this is a bit under there so
maybe it's about 5.8 5.97 21 actually is
five point nine five point nine one okay
so clearly number one it's just quick up
to estimate one number rather than two
secondly I get more accuracy like if
these are both off by a little bit then
when I multiply my little little errors
get bigger and bigger and bigger so here
I can go straight to much more accurate
idea so that's the multiplication right
beside that I want you to think about
division
so here's multiplication
if this is the way multiplication works
how do you think division works
because division of multiplications are
really two sides of the same coin right
in fact every division like this can be
written as a multiplication how would
you write this as multiplier out into my
it's 8 times what what is it about my
time and / - of course is 4 right so the
thing you've got to multiply 8 by
together fours uh-huh right so that's
the same thing okay
so therefore because multiplication and
division are really the same thing in
different clothes exactly the same idea
applies I can take two square roots and
I can combine those into one big one
right so I could say that's just a be
like that
it's just dividing cinnamon so as an
example
the square root of 6 divided by this
parameter to do because just like
multiplication with division I can
combine these two square roots these two
thirds into one big one right and of
course six divided by two is three so
you have the same advantages I was
mentioning before it's clearly better to
write 1.9 rather than 2 and excuse me I
don't have to approximate through
numbers and then try and calculate I can
just approximate one number and I'm
pretty sure that's about one point seven
three and you're going to see root 3
coming from your calculator a lot so you
probably get used to that as well right
so simple idea combined together when
you multiply combined together when you
do why maybe you want to put like a nice
big box around this and this because the
things you're going to refer to as we're
working through these why don't you have
a shot